اعلان الجيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي شنغارات
استهدفت مجمعا لتصنيع مكونات الصواريخ
تابعا لحماس في مخيم المغازي وسط غزه ردا
على اطلاق قبائل فصاروخيه من القطاع في
المقابل قالت كتائب القسام ان مضاداتها
الارضيه تصدت للطائرات الاسرائيليه ممدده
وفصائل فلسطينيه اخرى بالتصعيد الاسرائيلي
في غزه والضفه والتي قتلت اسرائيل فيها
فلسطينيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما الذي يؤشر اليه
استمرار جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في
اعماله القتاليه في كل من الضفه وغزه
دافعا بتعزيزات اللوجستيه مهمه في مواجهه
المقاومه
وكيف تتعاملوا القوس الفلسطينيه السياسيه
والمسلحه منها تحديدا مع هذه الممارسات
الاسرائيليه بما تشمله من اهداف ميدانيه
وسياسيه
والى اين تتجه الاوضاع في المنطقه بالنظر
الى فوز معسكر اليمين بقياده نتنياهو في
الانتخابات التشريعيه وابداء الاداره
الامريكيه خشيتها من انزلاق الامور الى
مزيد من العنف
[موسيقى]
تتسع رقعه التصعيد الامني لتشمل بتطوراتها
كل من الضفه وقطاع غزه في هذه وتلك تستمر
اسرائيل في ايكال معالجه الاوضاع الى
جيشها مره باختيالات بين قيادات ومنتسبين
المقاومه المسلحه في مخيم في الضفه واخرى
بغارات جويه يقول الجيش انها تستهدف موقعا
يسهم في تصنيع صواريخ تطلق بين حين واخر
على بلده اسرائيل الجيش الاسرائيلي قدم في
بيان بعض التفاصيل بشان غاراته التي قال
انها استهدفت مواقع عسكريه تابعه لحركه
حماس رد ان على صواريخ انطلقت من القطاع
باتجاه بلده اسرائيليه البيان يضيف ان
الغارات استهدفت مجمعا لانتاجه وتطوير
القذائف الصاروخيه ويضم مبنا لانتاج
المواد الكيميائيه المخصصه لانتاج
المحركات الصاروخيه اضافه الى ورشه تضم
موا خاما تستخدم في صناعه الصواريخ كما
استهدفت الغارات مجمعا ثالثا لانتاج وسائل
لتطوير انتاج القضاء في الصاروخيه اعتبر
الجيش الاسرائيلي هذه الغراب ضربه
لمحاولات حماس بناء قدراتها الصاروخيه
محمله للحركه المسؤوليه الكامله عن ما
سماها الخروقات الامنيه التي تستهدف
اسرائيل
حماس من جانبها وصفت القصفه الاسرائيليه
على قطاع غزه بانه عدوان سافر وامتداده
للحرب المفتوحه على الشعب الفلسطيني
الناطق باسم الحركه حازم قاسم في بيان
الله قال ان ما سماه الارهاب الصهيوني لن
يوقف ثوره الشعب الفلسطيني المتساعده
من جانبها قالت كتائب القسام الجناح
العسكريه للحركه الى القذف الاسرائيلي
استهدف موقعا لها وسط قطاع غزه
وفي الضفه الغربيه اعلى نجيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي انه اعتقل السته فلسطينيين
وبثت منصات فلسطينيات والمحليه على مواقع
التواصل مقاطع فيديو توثق لحظه اعتقال
جنود الاحتلال شابين في مخيم الدهيشه في
بيت لحم
[موسيقى]
والي مناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا في البدايه
من تل ابيب ران ادريس الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي اهلا بك سيد ادرس الى هذا الاصرار
من الجانب الاسرائيلي من صاحب القرار
الاسرائيلي على المعالجه الامنيه للاوضاع
بهذا الشكل الذي زاد من تدهورها كيف نفهم
نعم
اسالك تفضل
اعتقد ان هناك ترجمه
نعم كنت اسالك عن الاصرار من جانب صاحب
القرار الاسرائيليه على التصعيد نعم
هذا الاصرار من جانب صاحب القرار
الاسرائيلي على التوسيع بهذه الطريقه
استخدام الوضع الامني بطريقه ساهمت في
تدهور الاوضاع وليس تحسينها كيف نقرا
عايزين
ان ان الامر هو نفسه نفس اللعبه الدمويه
المكرره نفس السياسات لم يتغير شيء منذ 40
او 50 سنه وما يحصل حاليا هو ان بعد موجه
تين
نستطيع ان نعرف
ارهابيه او مقاومه او هجمات
الهدف مباراه ذلك هي القضاء على اخر موجه
من هذه الاعمال
نابلس لم تغير اي شيء هذه هي نفس السياسه
القديمه
لوجستيه الا يؤشر الى تعثر في تحقيق هذا
الهدف
مين ده يعني انه الا اذا ما غيرنا هنا نحن
في اسرائيل اذا ما غيرنا سياساتنا العامه
اذاعه المناطق المحتله والا اذا ما لما
بدانا بالتفكير بنفس سابق عندنا نحن نفكر
بالامر كل ما تقوم باسرائيل حاليا هي الرد
افعال وهذا طبيعي
فانت تحاول ان تهدئه وهذا ما يحصل
السيناريو الحقيقي خلف الكواليس هو ان
اسرائيل
لا تريد الحوار ولا تهديئه الوضع يعني اجد
مفارقه فيما تقول ان تريد ان تهدئه تهدئه
بالضرب والتصعيد يعني الا تتحسب اسرائيل
من ان تاتي افعلها بربما بمفعول عكسي يزيد
ينسد الافق السياسي ويزيد همم همم يعني اس
صوت البندقيه يعلو في الشارع الفلسطيني
والمشكله مشكلتنا نحن هو اننا لا نستطيع
ان نخرج من دوره الدماء هذه بسبب الافكار
السياسيه والايدروجين هذا ما يحصل وهذا
يحصل منذ سنوات وسنوات طويله وان الطريق
الوحيد اللي ايقاف هذا
الجلوس مع الفلسطينيين والتبادل الحديث
الاخرى يعني تتحدث عن الجلوس مع
الفلسطينيين ولكن ما يحدث على الارض شيء
مختلف تماما همم يعني خصوصا الان همم
وهناك من يربط بما همم تطورات الاوضاع على
الارض وما الت- والاجواء التي صاحبت
الانتخابات الاخيره
ما الت اليه نتيجتها
اعتقد
ان الحكومه الجديده الحاليه
تحاول ان تحقق شيئا ولكن لا يستطيعون بسبب
الانتخابات القادمه لا يمكن العدم القيام
باي شيء في الوقت الذي يقاتلون وتحاربون
ضد اشخاص
المناسبين وبالتالي
وبشكل العام
اتخذوا نفس السياسات التي اتخذت السياسات
السابقه التي اتخذها السياسه الحكومه
نتنياهو والفكره هي العمل تحت النفوذ
السياسيين والايدلوجيات وليس هناك من خيار
لهم سوى رد فعل المشكله ليس في الجنود
الجندي المسكين
الجنودكم
المشكله المشكله
على
[موسيقى]
العموم همم شكرا لك
اذا لتعميق النقاش ينضم الينا من غزه صالح
النعامي الخبير في شؤون الاسرائيليه من
نيوجرزي ايضا ينضم الينا ريتشارد اييه
عضو الوفد الامريكي في مفاوضات السلام في
الشرق الاوسط سابقا اهلا بكما معنا في ما
وراء الخبر وابدا معك سيد صالح النعامي
اذا هذه التطورات الامنيه كيف يقراها
الجانب الفلسطيني
هل يرى فيها ما قد يشي برباره النافعه
مثلا
بكل تاكيد في ما يتعلق بنتائج الانتخابات
الاسرائيليه فانا في تقديري المحصل العامه
ستكون ايجابيا لانه الذي حدث هذه النتيجه
تدلل بشكل لا يقبل التاويل يقنع العالم
اييي باسره بانه اسرائيل تتجه من طرف
التطرف الى جنون التطرف عندما تفرز
الانتخابات الاسرائيليه عن فوز الحركات
الدينيه الخلاصيه التي
ترى في التصعيد مع الفلسطينيين هو يعني
بمثابه
فريضه شرعيه على الاقل
تؤمن بذلك ثاني اكبر مركب في الحكومه التي
سيشكلها بيننا اياها وهي حركه تحالف حركه
الكاهنيه
والصهيونيه الدينيه التي بالمناسبه تطرح
افكارا لا يمكن الا ان تفضي الى ليس فقط
الى تصيد الى تحول غير مسموح وانا وانا لا
ابالغ قلت انه نتيجه هذه الانتخابات لا
تقل خطوره عن نتائج الانتخابات الالمانيه
في العام 1933 التي ادت الى صعود النازيه
يعني العصبي المثال عندما يطالب ايثمار
بين كبير زعيم الحركه الكاهاني وهو سيكون
ثاني اهم وزير في الحكومه الجديده عندما
يتعهد في الانتخابات اولا بطرد كل من يتهم
بالتحريض باسرائيل بان يفرض حكم الاعدام
على المقاومين بغض النظر عن عن عن الجنحه
التي ترتبط بالعمل المقاوم عندما يتعهد
همم
بتغيير اوامر اطلاق النار بحيث يسمح
للجنود بقتل الاكبر عدد ممكن من
الفلسطينيين نعم عندما عندما
يعني في الواقع الولايات المتحده عبرت عن
خشيتها من تزايد العنف وهمم هل هذا طبت
فقط ااا بظروف ميدانيه ام هناك فعلا دفع
سياسي لذلك عوده نتنياهو للواجهه وما تحدث
عنه صالح نعامي للتو من وجود اشخاص مثل
اثمار بنغفير في
مناصب رسميه مهمه جدا
اعتقد من من وجهه نظر اداره بيض
معظم الامريكان هذا التحالف الذي
انتخبه
ليس بالتقدم يتطور جيد فيما يتعلق تحقيق
السلام في المنطقه ان الشيء الطريقه
الوحيده الايجابيه للتركيب هذا
التشبيه الامريكي عند عندما
بفتح الابواب الصين وفعل ذلك بحيث الذي
كان ضد الشيوعيه قالوا اذا كان هو يقبل
ذلك طويل
معروف بهاء له في كل القدره هو كامل لم
يظهر ذلك لحد الان لكن لديه القدره هو
للسيد في طريق السلام بطريقه ربما حكومه
يساريه ما كانت تستطيع ان تقوم بها ربما
انا افكر تفكير ايجابي والاقنا اعتقد هذا
الشيء الوحيد الايجابي والا فان اتفق معكم
هذا ليس بالتطور ايجابي
وزير الخارجيه
عندما اجر اتصال هاتفيا مع رئيس الوزراء
ووزير الخارجيه الاسرائيلي يير لبيت اعرب
خلال تلك المكالمه بلينكن عن مخاوف كبيره
لدى بلاده ازاء الوضع في الضفه الغربيه
وشدد على قلق الاداره الامريكيه اذا
التوترات المتزايده واعمال العنف وفقدان
الاسرائيليين وفلسطين لحياتهم وتابع انه
من المهم والضروري ان تحقق الاطراف كافه
تصعيد الوضع او تخفف من تصعيد الوضع
وشدد كذلك على مكانه العلاقات الثنائيه
بين اسرائيل والولايات المتحده
اذا صالح النعامي ماذا تقرا في ثنايا هذا
التعليق منكم
يعني
الاداره الامريكيه قلقه تحديدا من نتائج
الانتخابات الاسرائيليه
لان هذه نتائج ستحرج الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وحتى حتى هذه اللحظه
الرئيس بايرن لامي يعني يهنينا نتنياهم
بفوزه واو كذلك الى الى السفير الاسرائيلي
في في السفير الامريكي في اسرائيل
لكن واضح تمام ان هذا لن يغير من من
محددات العلاقه الامريكيه الاسرائيليه وقد
اعبر عن ذلك انتم يمكن في اخر في اخر همم
رسالته
لانه
مثانه همم العلاقات الامريكيه الاسرائيلي
لم تتغير وستبقى متينه وهذا ان دل على شيء
فانما يدل على انه هذه ال- ال- الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه حتى في ظل الحكومه
الجديده حكومه التحالف الكاهنيه مع حزب
النقود ستواصل دعم اسرائيل وان كانت
سياستها ستفضي الاحراج الاداره الامريكيه
واحراج حتى حلفاء
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في المنطقه
على نتذكر انه ثمار بين كبير والحركه
الكهانيه وتحالف الصهيوني ديني ليس فقط
ومعني بالتصعيد العسكري فقط معنيين بتغيير
الوضع القائم في المسجد الاقصى وعبر عن
ذلك ثمار بني كبير بشكل واضح وصريح ويريد
استنساخ تجربه ما يحدث المسجد الابراهيمي
تقاسم الزمان والمكان ينقله الى القدس
وبالتالي اذا سمحتي فقط اريد ان انقل فكره
هذه الدعوه للتهدئه من الجانب الامريكي
هل المقصود فعلا همم هل هناك رؤيه مثلا
امريكيه
لتفعيل هذه التهدئه ام ايه هو حديث مجرد
لرفع عتب لا اكثر ولا اقل
اكيد هذه صوره معقده جدا نفسه
لديه علاقه طويله تعود الى اكثر من عقب
الزمان
[موسيقى]
مهما النفوذ الامريكي على ما يمكن ان تقوم
به اسرائيل في الضفه الغربيه طبعا هناك
النفوذ او التاثير الاقتصادي والمعنوي
والدعم للمنطقه والتاكيد ايضا صحيح عندما
يقبل بين العلاقات الامريكيه مع اسرائيل
لم تتغير بتغيير الوزراء رؤساء الوزراء
فهذا يعني ان هناك
في الولايات المتحده وفي
الاختبار لا لا احد يشك بان مشاكل في
البلدين ولكن من حيث الجوهر هناك وحده في
التزامات واعتقد ان مع ينبغي ان يقوم به
الرئيس
بان من مصلحته هو مصلحه نتنياه ان يحافظ
على السيطره الامور ولا يتحرك بشكل اعدائي
جدا الغربيه لعب بان كل علاقات الاتحاد في
المنطقه ولا بدات الاربع سنوات بعد
اتفاقات ابراهام هذه استعرض للخطر اذا ما
بلغت نتنياهو فيها قراراته والسياسيه
يتحدث عن وحده في الالتزامات ومصالح من
حيث رؤيه يعني مسار التطبيع يستمر صالح
النعامي هل هناك وحده في الصف الفلسطيني
وخصوصا ان هناك مسيرات في غزه وهمم قيادات
الفصائل خرجت تطالب بوحده الصف همم نوع من
التنسيق على خلفيه همم ما حصل في الجزائر
والمصالحه الاخيره هل هناك ما يؤشر الى
ربما موقف مختلف والى تحقيق نوع من
التنسيق لم نشهده من قبل هذه المره
انا فقط
الامريك احترام الخيارات الديمقراطيه
للاسرائيليين ايضا هتلر عندما فاز في 1930
الى 30 فاز بالانتخابات ديمقراطيه والعالم
يعلم ما كانت نتائج هذا الفوز الان بالرد
على سؤال ليلى انا في تقدير انه
الفلسطينيين ليس لم يعد لديهم ثمه خيار
يعني لم يعد هناك يعني طرف
الانتظار لمساله نتائج لقاءات الجزائر او
القاهره او بيروت او اسطنبول او غزه او
رام الله الفلسطينيون الان امام اختبار
صعب جدا الحكومه الاسرائيليه القادمه في
ظل سياسات التي تتفاعل حاليا في الضفه
الغربيه وقطاع غزه هذه الحكومه حرب كل ما
تعني الكلمه هذه الحكومه يعني اذا يعني
يعني سياسات ستتحرق الاخضر ولابس ما لم
يتوصل الفلسطينيون ليس فقط من باب يعني
اسطوانه يعني حل انهاء الانقسام هناك حاجه
لوحده الصف الفلسطيني لانه بدون هذه
الوحده فانه اسرائيل في طور انهاء او
الساعه لانهاء التصفيه القضيه الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه وبالتالي يجد تمت خلال
روسيا اتهمت واشنطن بتعطيل عمل الرباعيه
واجهاض اي تاثير لها في عمليه السلام هل
واشنطن مستعد لمراجعه موقفها خصوصا مع
عوده نتنياهو الى الواجهه
العرب
في
اي موضوع حاليا هذا غير مقبول حاليا لا
يمكن لروسيا
ان يكون مقوله من اي حكومه مسؤوله في
العالم
طريقه تعاملها فيما يتعلق باللجنه
الرباعيه
واعتقد مره اخرى ان هذا الامر لابد ان
يقنع
الفلسطينيين
فلسطينيين بنلاقي
الامريكي
وشكرا لصالح النعامي الخبير في الشؤون
الاسرائيليه من غزه
وشكرا لكم على المتابعه في مله
[موسيقى]